На цих кадрах призначений Кремлем так званий голова Запорізької обласної адміністрації Євген Балицький повідомляє мешканців Мелітополя
про підготовку до референдуму щодо входження регіону до складу Росії.
Передбачається, що референдум буде проведено вже 11 вересня у єдиний день голосування в Росії.
Навіщо такий поспіх? На думку експертів, однією з цілей Москви може бути подальша умисна ескалація конфлікту.
Можливо, одне із пояснень, яке напрошується, що це буде територія Росії.
І якщо українські війська прийдуть туди, то це буде напад на Росію.
І буде вже інший статус того, що відбувається. Вже не спеціальна операція, а повноцінна війна. На нас напали. Хоча на нас і так напали.
Але тут буде буквально такий територіальний напад. Можливо, намагаються зафіксувати успіх.
Хоча насправді це успіх відносний. І з можливими збитками. З можливою згодом поразкою.
Один із таких потенційних "збитків" - неможливість для Росії будь-яких подальших спроб розпочати переговорний процес,
про що негайно заявив президент Зеленський.
Позиція нашої держави залишається такою самою, як і була раніше: ми нічого свого не віддамо.
І якщо окупанти підуть шляхом цих псевдореферендумів, то вони закриють для себе будь-яку можливість переговорів з Україною та вільним світом,
які російській стороні однозначно знадобляться у певний момент.
Німецькі експерти сумніваються, що так званий референдум у Запорізькій області про приєднання до Росії
взагалі буде проведено принаймні в найближчому майбутньому.
Те, що зараз відбувається вони розцінюють радше як "промацування ґрунту".
Досі Кремль так і не дав чіткої відповіді, не сказав ні "так", ні "ні".
Він увесь час заперечував, що це стоїть на порядку денному.
Все виглядає так, ніби російському керівництву ще не до кінця зрозуміло, чого воно хоче, або що йому буде вигідніше.
Можливо, проросійське угруповання на півдні України зараз намагається це форсувати. Це могло б бути поясненням того, що відбувається.
Ми не можемо сказати, що рішення про референдум ухвалено.
Я б тут був поки що обережний. За всієї централізації влади та прийняття рішень лише однією людиною в Кремлі,
все одно є спроби радикалізації ситуації "знизу". Рішення буде ухвалено лише тоді, коли референдум реально відбудеться.
Деякі колабораціоністи намагаються "протиснути" це рішення у Кремлі.
Не варто забувати, що бої продовжуються, Україна оголосила про наступ на Херсонщині.
Розклад сил на полі бою може змінитися, і, швидше за все, саме тому Кремль поки що не ухвалив остаточного рішення про референдум.
Але в будь-якому разі, якщо референдум таки станеться, із законом і легітимністю він не матиме нічого спільного, наголошують експерти.
Напрошується порівняння цього ймовірного референдуму щодо приєднання Запоріжжя до Росії з тим,
що пройшов у Криму в березні 2014-го. І це порівняння, на думку експертів, далеко не на користь нинішньої ситуації.
Кримський референдум, ніким, окрім Росії та її сателітів, всерйоз не прийнятий, був все-таки відносно кращий за якістю,
ніж очікувані референдуми на цих напівзахоплених територіях. З простих причин.
У Криму хоча б збереглося населення. А ось ці території, про які йдеться - чи то Херсонська область, чи то Запорізька область -
там же значна частина, а може, й половина населення просто перебуває як біженці або в Росії, або в Україні, або в Європі - не має значення.
Яке до біса, пробач господи, народне волевиявлення, якщо значна частина виборців просто відсутня?! Як їх можна опитати?!
Опитані DW експерти сходяться на думці, що підсумки цього так званого референдуму, як і 2014-го, не будуть визнані ніким,
окрім самої Росії та кількох країн, які з різних причин залежать від неї.
Але Кремлю зовнішнього визнання і не треба - подібні референдуми орієнтовані виключно на внутрішню аудиторію.
Якщо той відбувався у Криму під дулами автоматів, то цей станеться під екранами моніторів.
І це головна зброя, яка в цій ситуації буде задіяна. Навіть нікого зганяти нікуди не треба.
Буде одна чи дві показові дільниці, які будуть зроблені для зйомок, куди організовано привезуть кореспондентів федеральних телеканалів,
які там знімуть велику чергу, інтерв'ю зі щасливою сім'єю, яка виходить з виборчої дільниці
та трясе над головою розкритим паспортом зі словами "який я щасливий, що мені вдалося взяти участь у цій історичній події"…
Цю декорацію вони поставлять. Цей театр вони зіграють.
Тим часом, на думку експертів, проведення так званого референдуму у Запорізькій області
лише спричинить новий виток напруженості - партизанську війну та постійні обстріли.